Okay, here's my solution.
I define deal. It takes the number of hands and the number of cards in each hand.
And then I've also added in an optional parameter
to make the function a little bit more general.
Here I built up a normal poker deck
with the 13 different ranks and 4 different suits.
I have a list comprehension that goes over both of them
and makes a 52-card deck.
But I provide that as a parameter because you might want to
deal different types of decks.
In other games like pinochle, you have a different number of cards.
I just want to make deal a little bit more general, so I provide that
as an optional parameter.
Then I randomly shuffle the deck,
and if you looked up in the random module, you see there is a function called shuffle.
That's the one you want.
And then I go through, and for the number of hands
I take a slice out of the deck which has been shuffled
and accumulate that into the result list.
Now, let's look a little bit more carefully at exactly
what this expression here means, pulling out this slice.
I've got a deck of cards which have been shuffled,
so they're not in any particular order.
Say the 3 of clubs is first, and then the 7 of spades, and so on.
And now I want to pull out this slice out of the deck,
which is defined as the deck starting at n x i
and going up to n x (i + 1).
And we'll assume for now that n = 5.
When i = 0, then this will go from 0 to 5.
And we'll pull out the first 5 cards, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
That slice will be the first element that we'll pull out.
Now when i is equal to 1, we're dealing to the second player,
and 5 x 1 is 5, 5 x 1 + 1 is 10,
and we'll pull out the next 5 cards.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and so on.
We'll keep on going until we get numhands different cards and return them in a list.
Now let's just make sure this works.
Let's print, and let's just deal out 2 hands.
And there we see we get 2 hands back.
There are 2 total hands, and each of them has 5 cards.
If we wanted to, we could deal different numbers of cards,
so here we deal 2 hands, and they each have 7 cards.